because how about this taurus snaps off
19th century statue
he's a tourist snaps toes off 19th
century statue while posing for a photo
cuz why did you do that
because i saw the toes on that statue
and i had to get them in my purse so i
could take them home later and put them
in my mouth
yeah cause i mean you want to snap toes
off the statue
you're a sick sick [ __ ] because i got
kicked out of the metropolitan museum
one time
for sucking on achilles toes how do you
deal with not being able to go to
museums how have you been
been holding back some prances well
after high school i
yeah i like not being able to prance is
tough but after college me and my friend
todd robinson
um who's a black guy who didn't give you
any money at your wedding
me and ty robinson traveled europe
together um you know my roommate from
college
and when you don't answer you know it's
true yeah
and uh what can you do listen not
everyone's good listen that doesn't mean
anything
okay it's just not everyone's gonna know
to do that you know
right i think it's more that i think
maybe he just didn't know that you're
supposed to but
you know i don't get married in a castle
i mean you got to know
so we would give europe you know give at
least a [ __ ] scratch off
i mean you know yeah i mean and i lead
sent me a [ __ ] scratch off in an
envelope that's the least anyone could
have done
at least okay and your mom sets a car
because i i want almost a tragedy in my
life to happen
so i can get a card from your mom she
i'll take her good energy if you don't
want it i love it
yeah your mom her uh my mom she'll find
your new address
she'll find a way to get you a mass card
she's just a sweet sweet woman and i
feel for her
anyway i've got to say um so we were in
europe and you know they have
david is behind glass that's because i
tried to suck on his toes
it's what it is yeah david he got his
feet licked
yeah um all right here we go so it's
time to wait i just want to tell you
what one of our fans said
on my uh video the other day they said
uh they said
if yani's eyes were any closer together
they'd be chrissy's toes
ten out of ten yeah so that's a ten so
shout out
whoever said that yeah that's the count
um
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild